Traduttore: Michele Gianella
Revisore: John Ockey
Io vorrei condividere con voi
lo stupore che ho provato
quando mi hanno spiegato
come le tecnologie esponenziali
stanno trasformando il mondo.
E per questo intervento mi sono dato
un obiettivo ambizioso:
vorrei che questo termine risultasse
indelebilmente fissato nella vostra testa.
Vediamo se riuscirò a fare questo.
Un po' come succede
con questa immagine, piena di macchie.
All'interno di questa immagine
c'è un cane, eccolo qua.
Ora che vi ho mostrato il cane,
non riuscirete più a non vedere il cane.
Provateci un po'?
Ecco, non ci riuscite, perché si è creata
una connessione neurale permanente.
Vediamo se riesco a fare la stessa cosa
parlandovi di tecnologie esponenziali.
Il significato di questo termine
l'ho appreso frequentando
la Singularity University,
che si trova all'interno del campus
del centro di ricerca della NASA,
a Mountain View, in California.
E qui, i maggiori esperti del mondo
studiano tecnologie come l'informatica,
le biotecnologie,
l'Intelligenza Artificiale
per capirne gli impatti
positivi e negativi.
Per la verità,
si fa molto di più di questo,
ma di questo ve ne parlerò dopo.
Stupore, dicevo.
Cosa hanno di così speciale
queste tecnologie esponenziali?
Hanno di speciale
che si sviluppano molto lentamente,
e poi all'improvviso esplodono.
Un po' come succede con i pop corn.
L'effetto pop corn l'abbiamo visto,
ad esempio, all'opera con Internet.
Internet è stato inventato 50 anni fa,
per 40 anni praticamente
non se n'è accorto nessuno;
poi, all'improvviso, paf!
Ogni pizzeria ha un sito,
miliardi di persone
sono connesse ad Internet,
il commercio elettronico
ha raggiunto una quota
di cinque miliardi di dollari al giorno.
Internet è diventato
il sistema nervoso del pianeta.
Ora non siamo stupiti, di questo,
ma se qualcuno ce l'avesse detto
dieci anni fa, o 15 anni fa,
non ci avremmo creduto.
Perché?
Perché quando il progresso è già avvenuto
noi lo diamo per scontato,
mentre invece,
quando dobbiamo fare delle previsioni,
le facciamo in modo lineare.
Come per esempio in modo lineare
ha pensato Mc Kinsey
quando, nel 1984,
ha stimato il mercato mondiale
dei telefoni cellulari dell'anno 2000.
La stima di Mc Kinsey era:
entro il 2000, ci saranno
un milione di telefoni cellulari.
Però nel 2000 ce n'erano 100 milioni,
e ora sappiamo che ce ne sono miliardi.
Perché ha sbagliato?
Perché qui avevamo
a che fare con un esponenziale.
Facciamo proprio fatica
a capire l'esponenzialità,
e ora ve lo dimostro con un esempio:
immaginate di fare 30 passi da un metro,
in modo lineare: uno, due, tre.
Dopo 30 passi,
sarò arrivato in fondo alla sala.
Ora immaginate di fare gli stessi 30 passi
raddoppiando i metri con ogni passo:
due, quattro, otto, 16.
Dove sarete arrivati,
dopo 30 di questi raddoppi?
Avrete percorso
oltre un miliardo di metri,
che equivale a fare 26 volte
il giro della Terra.
Quando mi hanno fatto questo esempio,
sono rimasto basito,
perché mi ha fatto capire
come non siamo in grado
di capire l'esponenzialità.
Per esempio, ci viene naturale pensare
che dopo 15 passi esponenziali,
quindi dopo 15 raddoppi,
saremo a metà strada,
cioè a circa 500 milioni di km.
Invece, dopo 15 raddoppi
abbiamo fatto 30 km,
che equivale alla distanza
fra Como e Lecco, praticamente,
e non 13 volte il giro del pianeta.
Ma ritorniamo sui cellulari.
Questo qui non è un telefonino,
questo è un supercomputer,
che 20 anni fa avrebbe riempito
una stanza intera,
e che fra 20 anni
occuperà lo spazio di una cellula.
E questo lo sappiamo
praticamente per certo
grazie a questo signore
che si chiama Ray Kurtzweil,
che è il fondatore
della Singularity University,
nonché praticamente il futurista
che ha azzeccato più previsioni
di chiunque altro al mondo.
Questa è la copertina di "Time"
dedicata alle sue previsioni
e alla sua famosa curva esponenziale,
che adesso vediamo meglio qui,
su questa slide.
Questa curva dimostra
che l'efficienza informatica,
per usare una semplificazione,
è andata raddoppiando in maniera costante
praticamente da un secolo a questa parte,
ancor prima dell'invenzione
dei circuiti integrati.
Se proiettiamo questa curva in avanti,
fra dieci anni, con 1000 euro,
saremo in grado di comprare
la capacità di calcolo
di un cervello umano.
E fra 30 anni, quando cioè i miei figli
avranno, più o meno, la mia età,
la capacità di calcolo
di tutti i cervelli umani.
Wow.
Cosa significa questo?
Questo significa che si verificherà
la cosiddetta Singolarità Tecnologica,
cioè quel momento ipotetico nel tempo
in cui le macchine diventano
più intelligenti di noi,
soltanto perché cresce in maniera
così enorme la capacità di calcolo?
Questo non lo sa nessuno,
e non lo sa nemmeno
la Singularity University:
proprio non lo sa nessuno.
Però è certo che questo
è un tema molto importante.
E dobbiamo, come dire,
avere un dibattito su questo tema,
che per la verità è già cominciato
e che pone interrogativi fondamentali
sul piano etico e sul piano filosofico.
Ma lasciamo da parte
un attimo l'informatica.
La vera novità,
e questo è il più importante
contributo di Kurtzweil,
è che sono esponenziali
tutte le tecnologie
che sono basate sulle informazioni.
Questo cambia completamente tutto.
Questo significa
che intelligenza artificiale, robotica,
biologia sintetica, nanotecnologie,
e tutte queste tecnologie -
ce ne sono delle altre -
sono esponenziali.
E queste, tra l'altro,
si accelerano a vicenda
perché si fertilizzano a vicenda.
E questo significa
che quello che abbiamo visto
con questa roba qui
è il preludio di un cambiamento
molto più epocale,
che ci coglierà completamente di sorpresa.
Questo è un esempio
di esponenziale potentissimo.
Vi ricorderete che nel 2003 -
c'è scritto 2013, ma dev'essere 2003 -
è stato annunciato il successo
del progetto di decodifica
del genoma umano.
Ci sono voluti 13 anni
e un investimento
di tre miliardi di dollari.
Oggi, per decodificare un genoma umano,
ci si mette una settimana
e costa 1.000 dollari.
E nel 2020, probabilmente,
ci vorranno dieci minuti
e costerà un centesimo.
Praticamente,
la biologia si è fusa con la chimica
che si è fusa con l'ingegneria
e soprattutto si è fusa con l'informatica.
E ora guardiamo alle cellule
come dei processori
e al DNA come a un linguaggio
di programmazione
sul quale potremo intervenire ,
nel bene e nel male;
io sostengo soprattutto nel bene.
Certo è che qui sta nascendo
una industria gigantesca,
un po' come è successo con i computer
quando è arrivato il personal computer.
Parlando di "fertilizzazione",
questo è un altro esempio
di fertilizzazione informatica:
la macchina auto-guidata,
che è praticamente il matrimonio
tra una macchina e un computer.
Questa macchina ha compiuto
milioni di chilometri senza alcun danno,
diciamo senza incidenti di rilievo.
Se il buongiorno si vede dal mattino,
questo significa che qui c'è il potenziale
per salvare un milione di vite umane,
che già di per sé sarebbe
un cambiamento profondissimo.
Però, i cambiamenti
che, diciamo, arriverebbero,
se si affermasse la macchina auto-guidata,
vanno anche molto più in là.
Per esempio, pensate a come cambierebbe
l'architettura delle nostra città,
che oggi sono piene zeppe di parcheggi,
pensate alla mobilità
di persone anziane e disabili:
il business delle assicurazioni
sarà completamente sconvolto.
E poi, quale sarà l'impatto sul PIL
nell'aver eliminato miliardi di ore
trascorse in questo modo.
Per non parlare del fatto
che queste macchine
sono dei super generatori di dati,
dati che potremo utilizzare
per creare nuovi servizi.
Parlando di dati,
la crescita delle informazioni digitali
è esponenziale anch'essa.
Questo è un famoso calcolo,
fatto da Eric Schmidt di Google,
che ha calcolato
che dall'inizio dei tempi fino al 2003
abbiamo prodotto 5 miliardi di gigabyte
di informazioni, di dati.
La stessa quantità l'abbiamo prodotta
in due giorni nel 2010
e la stessa quantità l'abbiamo prodotta
in dieci minuti nel 2013.
Abbiamo cominciato col testo,
poi le foto, poi i video, poi i social.
E adesso arrivano gli oggetti:
si calcola che entro dieci anni
gli oggetti connessi ad internet
saranno 1.000 miliardi.
Questa frase:
"La tecnologia sostituirà l'80%
dei dottori entro dieci anni" -
questo lo sostiene il fondatore
di Sun Microsystems -
potrà sembrare fantascienza,
e forse lo è; non lo sappiamo.
Certo è che anche la penicillina
sarebbe sembrata fantascienza nel 1900,
la TAC fantascienza nel 1950
e la stessa decodifica
del genoma umano nel 1990.
Le tecnologie esponenziali stanno sfumando
i confini fra fantascienza e realtà.
E questa, per esempio, è realtà
ed è anche fantascienza messe insieme.
Questo è un premio messo in palio
dalla fondazione X-Prize e da Qualcomm,
di 10 milioni di dollari,
che praticamente ha lanciato una sfida:
hanno lanciato una sfida
a startupper e ricercatori,
per creare un palmare,
per intenderci, come quello di Star Trek,
in grado di battere dieci dottori
nel diagnosticare
le più frequenti malattie.
Il vincitore sarà annunciato a breve;
altro che fantascienza!
Altro esempio: nanotecnologie applicate
all'efficienza dei pannelli solari.
Anche qui assistiamo
a dei raddoppi di efficienza
da diverso tempo a questa parte.
Se questo trend continua -
fantascienza, ancora una volta -
fra 20 anni avremo risolto
il problema dell'energia.
E, ancora più importante,
avremo risolto il problema dell'acqua,
che è strettamente connesso
a quello dell'energia.
Grandi trasformazioni in atto, allora.
E siamo preparati?
A giudicare dall'esempio
che avevo fatto prima, direi di no.
Non siamo preparati,
c'è proprio un gap cognitivo.
Le tecnologie esponenziali vanno così,
e il nostro modo di pensare va così.
Lo vediamo anche dal fatto
che lavoriamo, funzioniamo,
utilizzando delle strutture
che si basano su modelli organizzativi
creati 100-200 anni fa.
I governi, le scuole,
il sistema dei brevetti,
il sistema legale,
tutti modelli organizzativi pensati
per un mondo che era lineare,
sostanzialmente statico
e quindi anche abbastanza prevedibile.
Mentre questo mondo,
presto, non esisterà più.
E la cosa importante
è che questo cambiamento è in atto,
è reale ed è inarrestabile,
e allora porterà con sé una serie -
come sempre, col progresso -
di minacce e di opportunità,
di pericoli e di opportunità.
Ecco, parlando di pericoli io,
come padre di questi tre bambini
il pericolo lo prendo molto sul serio, no?
Ho sentito parlare
di privacy, cyberterrorismo,
algoritmi software
che distruggono posti di lavoro,
alienazione della realtà virtuale,
e chi più ne ha più ne metta.
Ma dubito che mettersi il casco
risolva il problema.
Piuttosto, dobbiamo intervenire
su quello che sta sotto il casco.
Io, personalmente,
penso che sia molto importante
cambiare la nostra mentalità.
Avere una mentalità
orientata al cambiamento,
una mentalità orientata all'innovazione
e una imprenditorialità orientata,
improntata alla sostenibilità
e all'uso delle tecnologie a fin di bene.
E questa è un po', diciamo, l'idea,
una delle idee fondamentali
della Singularity University,
sulla quale torno adesso.
La Singularity University
seleziona, tutti gli anni,
i più brillanti talenti del mondo,
li fa venire in California
e dice loro: "Ragazzi,
non siete qui soltanto per studiare.
Scegliete uno di questi problemi,
e date un contributo.
Pensate a come si possono usare
le tecnologie esponenziali
per impattare positivamente
un miliardo di persone
entro dieci anni.
Una sfida unica ed entusiasmante.
E poi, i migliori progetti
vengono selezionati
e diventano o progetti di ricerca,
oppure vengono, diciamo, incubati
e diventano dei business.
Incubati direttamente
dalla Singularity University.
Adesso vi faccio vedere
un esempio di questi progetti,
realizzato da un italiano,
un giovane talento di 22 anni,
Alberto Rizzoli,
che ha scelto il problema della salute,
in particolare quello della cecità,
e la tecnologia scelta
è quella dell'intelligenza artificiale.
Ha sviluppato un'applicazione
che serve ai ciechi
per riconoscere gli oggetti
che si trovano di fronte a loro.
Vediamo.
[Italiano ] AR: Aipoly è un sistema
intelligente per ipovedenti
che permette loro di esplorare
e comprendere i dintorni
attraverso una visione-macchina
e un feedback audio.
L'utente scatta una foto,
che è caricata automaticamente
sui nostri server,
che la analizzano e la taggano.
E poi l'utente riceve una descrizione,
pronunciata con la sintesi vocale.
TTS: Stai guardando una donna
con occhiali da sole neri
e una T-shirt azzurra.
Stai guardando delle camicie rosa,
nere, e grigi a scacchi.
Utente: Wow, impressionante!
Sto elaborando...
Davanti a te ci sono
i nuovi auricolari Apple.
Utente: Wow!
È vero!
È quasi una magia!
È impressionante, sono senza parole!
Sono scioccato!
Ecco, avete visto, dice: "It's like magic".
Mi ha fatto pensare
a quella frase di Sir Clarke,
l'autore di "Odissea nello spazio",
che diceva:
"ogni tecnologia sufficientemente avanzata
è indistinguibile dalla magia."
Ecco, se abbracciamo il cambiamento,
invece di resistere, e lo cavalchiamo,
e se, diciamo,
immaginate un milione di imprenditori
tutti orientati a voler fare del bene,
oltre che del business,
ecco, i risultati sarebbero
indistinguibili dalla magia.
Grazie.
(Applausi)